and while my best friend's birthday is
on Sunday oh boy you're gonna watch
Manchester by the sea yeah the videos
going to birthday or watching young hi
guys I'm Greg I'm John we have this
smoke entrance yeah we're starting with
a fog machine for this one next one
we're going to have strobe lights too
and the third one you're actually going
to be able to purchase tickets and we'll
jump out and scary screen junkies
squanders junkies officers are coming up
you know what they did with their honest
trailers lots of requests it's that time
of the year when he'll age pretty
narcissist use their awards to take
shots at eat these ugly narcissus as
these nine films complete for
Hollywood's highest honor because back
when it was just by the Academy could
trick you into voting for something you
actually saw this year similar companies
work they picture are from Demi billing
you that will plump Amy Adams second
movie this year about trying to relate
to an alien no one good I'm trying to
wrap their mind around what they just
saw because they're pretty sure the part
about the Chinese guy makes absolutely
no quit for a first-time director Garth
Davis comes to film about the kid who
goes to any with Nicole Kidman my bank
and finds the lion or something oh right
it's the one with Deb Bedell here is
really good but honestly I've only seen
the trailer they've gotten some
believing i watch movies at the same
time if you shouldn't see this you're
probably lying has returned to West
Texas but the only after movie eyes get
really sure why do good to have really
work till morning this might not go down
we suspect it might be did for a film
that so entertaining straightforward and
unpretentious it has no chance of
actually winning Best Picture
hahaha
just a hearing for incredible until two
of the major contributions black women
makeable states program whose brilliance
was no match with a stubborn prejudice
of the times but don't worry it won't
make white people feel too bad about
themselves see Kevin Costner's want a
good ones diary of a black mass woman
from the writer of The Adventures of
Rocky and Bullwinkle way really comes
the exact opposite of that it's going to
God my knockers what as you take a
non-stop Greek Rick is that bill glad by
a hard-drinking irritable Boston man
living in the shadow of it's more
successful older brother we know how big
a black manage to get into character
Manchester by the fecking to follow
along the mullet unfolding of a lie
beautifully directed by Barry Jenkins as
this young black gay man struggles to
escape from poverty and drug addiction
told across three decades based on play
based on the life story of a talker oh
yeah I'd say somebody furniture on the
Oscar things clean on the stage play
Denzel Washington struck at the
beginning they're just talking in a half
the entire time as this actors bravely
explore how much acting you can fit into
one movie featuring Wow that day you
best be making sure they're doing right
by you knew on that day seventeen years
ago that boy when you won't get involved
in old school and not a game don't you
think I don't want another thing don't
you think I had dreams and hope what
about my life factory burns is rich to
Hollywood again oh Jesus movies he
filled with blood and gore with another
store
about a historical pacifist filled with
tons of what what was it necessary but
why they rip you war and pieces that's
an ox appearance ago added to the
musicals of famous cast that are
nominations for Best Picture Best Actor
Best Actress Best Director nice Best
Cinematography sure Best Screenplay
really best song okay I get that one
there's sound mixing fine dress come
again come on if nobody wants sing
Street best costume design they're just
wearing clothes and you can we just
can't resist a movie about how special
it'll be dark in a Hollywood hand job
those are your nominees for Best
honorable and this we bet there will be
a million speeches about Trump at the
Oscars we thought we get an equal time
to respond
he is Twitter in our starring picture
starring the highly overrated Meryl
Streep mar-a-lago only bad hombres
potential terrorists are in fix it best
this seven eight now that's a real
amount that spider-man I know that one
we're both between smart get OJ Simpson
great guy great golfer I'll turn it it
back
Oh sad sad sad sad sad the office thanks
for stopping by mr. president big views
you have fake views more like not honest
trailers low-energy Wow
Inez got another here and she's over
five when she is nominated
what's an actor got to do to finally win
an Oscar dude alright never mind hey
screen junkies want to watch the Oscar
with us then tune in this Sunday to our
officer watch party live on YouTube on
our screen junkies News Channel want you
off of your favorite screen junkies
personalities
starting at 5:00 p.m. Pacific time this
Sunday night as we give our honest take
on this year's ceremony
I wonder if while Island will win
anything Hot Diggity Dog I was a to obey
burger with cheese my vodka
hi my magical princess from another
dimension
furball Liam Neeson punches puppies five
virgins hi in the night I am well man
that might have been one of their best
honest trailers I've ever seen that was
yes it's pretty sure I was a really
sharp man that was super sharp so Amy
Adams is a nominee I don't think so I
don't remember the nominations
did it just just do an all-female remake
of the revenant Wow Amy Adams not
nominated nope I didn't realize that
that really sucks she did an amazing job
in arrival terrific can have new watches
so late like many weeks I've ever been
out that we didn't do a review of it man
she was fantastic at NASA yeah there's a
challenging role yeah that's a
challenging role I feel like this is a
genre and the plot of it yeah the way
it's fragmented yeah interspersed like
so much of what it ultimately comes
together the in that movie hangs on her
ability yeah to be our rock for this I
think is a really really raw emotional
performance yeah so that sucks yeah yeah
I love Amy Adam I do too I've seen a
good amount of these couple there tell
me you've seen or something I've seen
but we and I know there's a few that we
both miss there's that about fences it
is so true it was one of those feeling
I've seen the one of the best plays
adapted ever that I've ever seen into
film that was for a lot of it was
accurate to the play was going Gary Glen
Ross gentleman because it still feels
like a film yet the script is very true
to appointed king with this I call it it
actors looks great as I'm like yet this
the whole thing just feels like a stage
play it takes a while to adjust to it
and it gets so serious and so like
somber and depressing like halfway
through that you're not even crying
anymore you're just like you know we're
just this is where we've entered
depression we're all here to see
we're just sad now we're not either
we've cried enough of this is gonna be
here for a while it happen it's gonna
keep going
those are movies because I haven't had a
lot of like extra time to like go check
out all the Oscar movies but just a lot
of movies I want to see like that's one
run I really have to like prepare myself
to want to go there and in action we
have time to film stupid YouTube videos
of me why aren't you watching the movies
because I pay for one of those
activation and I also got to take time
out for both hacks all rich that's one
of my favorite movies of 2016 for sure
hack so rich so proud of Mel Gibson I
support Mel Gibson's comeback in case
you haven't addressed yet on this
channel I said every time I bring him up
but even before
Mel Gibson support was coming back it
wasn't like nobody's coming I didn't
like I've been talking about this guy
for a while man you've been there since
before the beaver day yeah I mean
there's a day one on like hey okay let's
let them chill out some chill out can
your sponge Joe algae comes back you
know yeah I'm not as quite as gung-ho as
you but you know what I do believe in
the idea that you know as long as you've
not done something like completely
unforgivable you can't correct with a
lot it with some soul-searching and with
some personal growth you know I'm not
about to be like nah we can never give
someone another chance like that yeah
does the director of Jeepers Creepers or
something like that I'll be like maybe
not let's not do that but hey I'm down
for giving the guy another shot that we
act if he's a better guy now cool let's
do it yeah and I heard hacks are
registered not they were peeing real for
a second that was a very over-the-top
death in that plays out better when you
watch it that was almost I mean like it
was good visceral and gruesome but it
was also like almost just like a ward s
so heightened yeah it's a war death
you're the war bullets or for a left and
right with [ __ ] ass alright well that
looks truly yunjin that looked nice
in a big way yeah do when they get to
that scene yeah there's a long time
before TC Milan yeah how does that mean
I had to go I feel gets picked on by
people and I am punching [ __ ] hensdale
the most badass seeing it it's got real
I forget did Jesus come at me I'm
spider-man spider-man will [ __ ] wall
a lava land is your favorite when you
first saw it I saw it in Zurich and now
I go really like classic small theater
in Zurich which is awesome and to be
like another country and watch a movie
of a takes place in the city I grew up
in yeah surely awesome maybe in it so a
lot and Shelley the law a lot I've seen
twice in the theaters and I think it's
the best film for me for me my choice
I'm not here to argue about other
technicalities I can see someone getting
a little questionable about Best
Screenplay for sure yeah and and about
what their economy and ein crack was
fair given else's around true I complete
I'll give it that but it's still my
favorite film of the year you know is we
get something's out the best script
necessarily there's more to lala land
cut out the costume design cracks yeah
because actually I crossings in there
because I do I get I get the I get the
meaning of that but at the same time I
came to sort of appreciate the the
subtle range I guess because there are
the movie jumps back and forth between
reality and fantasies and stuff like
that and there are costumes involved in
that so while there are a lot of things
around that are you know noticeably big
costume pieces I guess I can appreciate
I appreciate a you know simple but right
choice and distinct but simple choices
you know or more subtle choices and
where I'm coming up so just in case you
didn't an insurance policy I don't want
to be misunderstood never that high but
when you thought you were come on the
first thing you said to me with them so
glad I got to see it before all this
hate comes in for it yeah Google
consists that and I was like I don't
really do happening and then suddenly a
lot of April all I came in like a few
days after you said that and I wanna do
in my experience was like I saw and for
a little while people
I loved it so much and like I thought
you were right I was like maybe we could
get this far but also like people really
liked whiplash and I know pretty much
everybody I saw it told me a very
specific like why like more than one
person was like that movie really made
me feel like it well it was you know a
little spunky and rough around the edges
in places but like that was the one
animal made me feel some and I think
he's a Damien Chazelle is a good
director thought it might not set him
but it did it did set in it did set in I
think it's because wall on land it was
just a bigger film - it has a bigger
budget than whiplash it's a different
kind of song you're dealing with a
musical and you got two big stars in the
film it's going to get a lot more
attention so it's getting all this love
I think when people are going in there
go without I'm expecting to go in here
and just love every moment of this man
yeah and if they don't get even close to
a feeling they just go I don't like it
because I've heard people go I don't
like it and then they'll go don't get me
wrong
the music was great the acting was great
the singing was great but I didn't
really like the script
and then they just end it with that not
like there's more to film than that you
know this movie again is forced me to
look at the hype machine and what it
does and if it does I got to see it
before again the hype wave completely
hit before it was out at least before
there was an opening weekend for people
to come back angry from you know and so
I I saw it on my own you know the right
experience and so I felt all those
things that you're supposed to feel like
I had a wonderful experience watching
that movie and then when I watched it
again you know with more criticism in
the air I still felt all those things so
like for me I think it's I can tell you
all day about what I think is great
about it a movie like that is supposed
to pluck your emotions and then play
those strings and if they don't for you
I guess all you're left to do is analyze
it and some of the criticisms are fair
you know like I understand the dancing
is not like they're not trained singers
and dancers I understand why somebody
would get hung up on that me personally
I don't care like it does doesn't change
my experience and you know there are
submissions about like movies about jazz
all about why people I get it like this
that's probably the one thing I'm like
yes this is problematic I still love the
experience and the two
so um I like it I hope it winds up sir
too much
no I'm nodding my head and ingredients
say I don't know what to do with the
guy's a popper again a Marvel movie was
nominated for Best Visual Effects dr.
strange
it was dr. strangely that's cool and
wrote I won this is going to get some
more people to tune in not bad
so guys subscribe to screen junkies
check out John at the reasons to Gerry
on the tweets and the insta-tox
he's also the manager of a burger
because a social media manager Oh laughs
in the real region some house Jesus and
the real rejects throughout my ass I
didn't say anything
that's right Michelle was in Manchester
by the sea of course using something
depressing I wouldn't expect anything
less